not only is Lady Ballers the number one
streaming movie on Rotten Tomatoes we
also made it to Capitol Hill when
Congressman Eric burles my friend who
has been on this show before you might
remember him uh was uh questioning Riley
gains a star of the lady Ballers movie
on what is going on with women's sports
and the agenda check it out I just want
to say you know to to Mrs Gaines what
happened to you was is tragic I mean the
what you were robbed of your the glory
you were robbed of your opportunity to
um to be clearly the Victor and it's if
if it weren't so tragic it would be
comical I mean and I understand there's
a movie being made the comedy about this
very issue um that on the daily wire
that I can't wait to see I encourage
everyone to watch it um and truthfully I
think that's what's needed uh because
what we're seeing again what myself and
my teammates Ates and my competitors saw
was a mockery a mockery of women uh and
I believe it's time we mock the mockery
through comedy because you're right it's
objectively funny uh it's inherent to to
almost look at this and laugh because it
feels like satire uh but watching that
movie uh to which I watched uh it didn't
feel like satire it felt like a
documentary of what again myself and
girls around the country continue to go
through thank you my time has expired
really important point from congressman
burles and of course from Riley
gains this is called a hearing
on transgenderism in women's sports the
the way that this has all been framed is
is about women's sports and that's a
little bit misleading I think
because no one actually cares about
women's
sports if this were just about women's
sports people would write it off say
don't we have bigger issues in America
yeah maybe it's a little wrong the
hulking dudes running and and beating
the women but like who you know we're on
the brink of World War III we got a
migration crisis who cares about women's
sports no one even shows up to watch
them no one no one goes to WNBA games
it's it's a minor issue I agree with you
no one actually cares about women's
sports that's not what this is about
what this is about is
Justice no I'm not I've never gone to
see a women's basketball game and I
never will I don't I don't even watch
men's sports really very small number of
exceptions that's not the problem here
the problem is that these women have
trained their whole lives they were told
that there are rules to the game they
were told that if they worked really
hard they could win a trophy and they
could get some Glory that they could get
even material benefit from it they could
get scholarships they could they could
go to the College of their dreams and
then that is being stolen from them by
men who are breaking the rules of the
game that's what's so wrong that's how
you get someone like me fired up about
this I don't I don't care about women's
sports at all and most people don't but
you don't need to care about women's
sports to recognize that this is
terribly wrong and it's deeply unjust
and it's dangerous for women don't
forget when when dudes started fighting
in women's MMA what happened immediately
the dudes started cracking the women's
skulls this is terribly dangerous it's
terribly wrong everything about it is
absurd that's what makes it a common
one of the critical reviews of Lady
Ballers said this this movie is actually
undercutting its argument that we need
to save women's sports because the joke
in the movie is that no one actually
shows up to women's sports and they
start showing up when the men infiltrate
the games no that the argument of the
movie is not that we need to save women
sports the argument of the movie is we
need to protect women and we need to
defend Justice that's the message of the
movie yeah the movie points out people
do want to go see men compete in sports
more than they want to see women because
men are bigger and faster and stronger
that's why it's so wrong to have them
running and swimming against the women
and certainly wrong to have them
punching the women in the face right now
go to jus.com
nsyt letter y letter T I have got a
Christmas gift idea that is sure to make
you the hero of the season now we all
know the holiday season can be a little
bit hectic the shopping the cooking the
long list of things to do Fe you're not
because I've discovered a gift that is
both thoughtful and transformative the
gift of Jus cell skincare from now until
Christmas Jus cell's most popular
package has a discount just for our
listeners at jus.com letter y letter T
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles Fine
Lines skin redness sagging jaw line will
disappear right before your eyes with
jus cell's most popular collection Jus
cell promises immediate effects you will
see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back their
products use the best stuff out there on
the market the prices are incredibly
competitive and in fact they will give
you special holiday disc accounts
because they know even if they lose
money on this order they know that you
are going to keep coming back that is
how good it is go to jus.com
nsyt get this incredible holiday
discount today every order is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping
jus.com
nsyt today we here at the daily wire we
cannot stop suing the Biden
Administration we just love it it's one
of our favorite hobbies and this is
breaking news it just came out we are
suing Biden's State Department this is a
lawsuit with the Federalist and with the
state of
Texas uh we are suing the state
department because we now have very
strong evidence that the state
department spent money to destroy our
business the US state department which
is tasked only with dealing with foreign
affairs which is prohibited from
wielding its power
on domestic ISS issues certainly against
domestic perceived enemies the state
department used its money to destroy the
daily
wire how did they do that they used
government
money they then within the state
department turned the global engagement
Center which is an office designed for
countering foreign terrorist
propaganda and they turned it on
so-called disinformation in the United
States this is a blatant violation of
the First Amendment
they uh the gec this this uh Center to
counter foreign terrorism in fact it was
founded as a center for strategic
counterterrorism Communications was
tasked with disrupting the
communications of al-Qaeda then Congress
uh clarified in 2016 that none of the
funds authorized for the entity quote
shall be used for purposes other than en
countering foreign propaganda and then
what happened the GE turned its focus
onto US onto Americans They promoted
pro-censorship leftist organizations
such as News Guard and the global
disinformation index we're considered
one of the worst offenders on the global
disinformation
index and and newscard hates us too
though and they try to censor us as well
and then they use that money to destroy
our business and not just us to destroy
the Federalist to destroy the New York
Post to destroy reason magazine Reon
magazine they're just some amiable pot
smoking Libertarians they're going after
reason too reason is barely it's hard to
even call that right-wing it's vaguely
right-wing State Department going after
them too so we are suing them we love
suing the Biden Administration we've got
a pretty good track record suing the
Biden Administration so I think it's
going to work out very well and right
now in in DC the the Deep state does not
seem quite as omnipotent as it once did
they seem kind of blundering I'm
beginning to get the impression of the
deep State not that they are truly the
shadowy cabal of five people people
controlling the whole world I'm starting
to get the sense that it's like Burn
After Reading by the Cohen Brothers that
everything they touch turns to Ash
because they're extraordinarily
incompetent and they have bad motives as
well like trying to destroy our business
with money that that's supposed to be
used to disrupt foreign terrorists
theyve got bad motives too I'm not
denying that but they're just so
profoundly incompetent they use money to
try to destroy us every time they do it
our company doubles in size now we have
the biggest comedy movie in the country
on Rotten Tomatoes keep it up State
Department we sue you for this keep it
keep spending more money to destroy us I
think by the end of it we're going to be
the biggest media company in the world
man what a great clip that was now hey
hold up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see you
next time